bene di ragazzi benvenuti a questo
nuovissimo video su totali a great batte
il grande sono contento che vi sia
piaciuto così tanto ma perché
meraviglioso è veramente fantastico sto
cacchio di gioco l'unica roba
io continuerei a giocarlo per come l'ho
giocato finora e lo giocherei anche
online
perché c'è anche la modalità online che
sta ammazzando il mammut sistemazione
una volta a beatles coda rossa così in
gioco la nostra casa o fantastico gioco
è veramente incredibile pieno di roba
laboratorio
il workshop bellissimo guarda che cosa
puoi fare
nel multi giocatore poi giocare con gli
amici il locale a fare una partita
rapida online vediamo se riesco a fare
una partita da pina online e vediamo
cosa succede perché non non ancora
provato sicuramente saranno bravissimi
fratello mi avevi abbiamo 20 mila punti
a testa
ok io però non conosco nessuno di
sbadigli liste robeco a finire un crono
di minatore kick ass
non ho idea penso sia uno che i pochi
che in qualche modo tiene il tempo non
lo so ramponiere cannoniere mettiamo dei
cannonieri sulla nave visto che ci siamo
già rimaniamo in tema di scendono da una
sola in una roba sola in esso si parte
da faccio fuori subito
non ho neanche messo tutti gli altri ho
solo messo i cannonieri questo qua è una
battaglia tra ubriachi comunque gli
hanno tolto la pistola che i cannonieri
sono più briati di lui comunque
incredibile che non lo mancano tutti
attenzione è fortissimo ma chi è e morto
ma visto che l'ha messo solo quello
lasciato perdere perché potevamo mettere
tutti i due montatura perché non solo
quello poi all'interno un sacco zio è
metti un sacco di roba due giochi via
via cannonieri via canone o hai messo un
po di roba reggina pirata sofia ma ok
poi io prenderei un sacco ritira l'ance
ha proprio un sacco così trenk a non è
poi mettervi di un toto ok sassaiola
sassaiole non ne puoi metterti di un tot
come mai a puoi mettere al massimo 20
truppe ma perché metti sempre solo
quello 20 qualcun altro ma perché sono
quello guarda che schifo
animi lancieri che fanno veramente
ridere questo non lo so era la regina
pirata facile basta metterne uno basta
metterne uno mio avversario non è
proprio temibile 20 solo quello da
allora io metto un cavatore top
sì però dove alle pistole non vale e
forse era meglio non averle attenzione
chi è che ha lanciato un sasso non
valera uno contro uno
dove vai ce la vorrei ma su un tiro di
dietro a beck ha lanciato un sasso chi
sei
campagnolo cosa fa vedevo vedo bello
bello bello sobrio lo vedo che è
perfetta
beh non avevo dubbi guardando a come
dall'urlo di guerra l'avevo intuito che
non avrebbe vinto sto campagnolo però
senti basta e termina basse e stato
divertente zio però vorrei giocare con
un attimino un po più competitivo la
vogliamo smettere di mettere pistoleri
ubriachi è quello non so chi sia ma io
metto un monarca del vuoto un po di
licio della tempesta il cappio èquello
cose staro elefante sacro cosa sta
minkia sto vedendo elefanti sacri e ho
finito i soldi valgono pronto si va
detto con la messo un miliardo di
arcieri per farmi fuori delle fans è
tutto chiaro
checa successo chi sei tu identificati
cos'è sta roba qua è fortissimo ma chi è
è un portatore di morte no la rapitrice
la metto anch'io se posso se posto è
anzi mi metto due dopo due miti trici
faccio questo ho bisogno di 26
protettori davanti
dov'è il minotauro medioevo minotauro
mio tavolo due cazzo stai
no ho sbagliato ho schiacciato pronto
porco demonio non vale
ho sbagliato ho scherzato bayern
schiacciato pronto ma se non volevo
farlo vabbè ragazzi proviamo così a culo
il carro da vinci ok è quello che stavo
usando neanche piano della 4.000 per
forza che stava usando miliardo di robe
nuova elezione questo è il crono di
minatore a quanto pare non chiedetemi
cosa cacchio serve ma vedo che fa danno
immagino faccia c'era anche lui creare a
roma si guarda questa volta io ho fatto
il culo ragazzi siamo stati ho fatto il
culo stavolta gli ho fatto il culo
proprio lui ragazzi lo zio cambiato un
po il setup vedo lo zio si sta cagando
sotto la gara visto che cuoce c'è da
combattere lo zio visto che c'è da
combattere
quindi come biasimarlo allora vediamo un
po cambiato un po di roba lì
ha tentato di perché giustamente via
visto come come come compatto io allora
cambiato di conseguenza trovare una
bella idea su vedi quale quale la mia il
mio set up e cerchi di andargli contro
una bellissima idea questa non so se vi
è passato attenzione perché questa è
secondo me la sono giocata di nuovo bene
provvediamo lezione ci sono solo due
due cose e ho vinto vinto miss sono più
forte onlie che nella campagna raga
acceso un fenomeno cultore del nulla
eccolo proprio lui connessione persa se
n'è andato seccato sotto cacasotto lo so
allora la verità ricalcato da sotto
anch'io e che sono troppo forti
mammamia regala che soddisfazione delle
ci sono i run questo gioco di poker
league siamo secondo quello cosa sta
facendo madonna che tre ragazzine è una
battaglia sembra che stiamo giocando la
champions league
no non posso metterlo porco del demonio
facciamo così tac e rinascimento caro da
vinci
non so cosa succede ma vediamo
non so cup e il carro da vinci è caduto
vinto non si è capito niente
carlo non ha neanche il mammut non hanno
fatto niente
quello è uscito due ora l'impreparazione
un secondo di battaglia ho vinto ma non
si sa come ragazzi non perdona i ragazzi
della sua contro chi come che si
chiamano questo non lo so ma siamo nel
selvaggio west
e io visto che voglio essere coerente
con la mappa metterò un po di giorgio
coni sono in questi anche il calcio puoi
sparare anche d'acqua bellissimo vuoi
vedere che succede se lo metto qua
lavoro per curiosità il suo nome si
ammazza cade ridotto però va bene ok
let's go
quel tipo ha tolto tutto vale appena
aveva detto metterà un gigante poi fa
pronto a scommettere no agli ammessi
sono più lontani va bene ma mi avrà
buona formazione ragazzi la mia la buona
formazione mi piace qui cannonieri non
so prendono distanza giustamente perché
mi vuole far fuori subito
ok ci sta è il cane ma postali è per
niente di fatto la stessa cosa più
distante bravo sì ci sta perché io posso
anche togliere pronto ma questo non lo
voglio fare
qui sono guaritori con quel carro armato
come cacchio form sbloccarsi ste cose no
voglio saperlo
dopo vado a vedermi come si sbloccano
perché non lo so è il secondo video che
faccio sta roba quindi alcune cose non
le so ragazzi mi sono messo più indietro
possibile per vedere che succede non
sono neanche asi 1 la presa
alcune palle l'anno colpiti non so come
ha quindi forse il carro armato non era
quello era la mitraglia
allarmato quanto vale finché è
fortissimo non si può non si possono
battere senza si ferì abbiati oggettivo
di tipo battere quindi mi sta divertendo
troppo che ha chiuso noi dovremmo avere
tutti gli stessi oggetti
se no è impossibile madonna è finita no
sono ancora in sti due sono stati per
poco vabbè peccato ragazzi peccato di
sblocco poi tutti gli oggetti non so
come però vabbè vanno sbloccati per
forza ci proviamo così almeno anche on
line non c'è un modo di perdere
sostanzialmente che senza quelli touch
app inter chi parte da ragazzino mi
piace anche al socialista d'estinzione
il senatore si discute m come sempre ci
vediamo al prossimo video bella ragazza
[Musica]